avec les mangas une vraie polémique
démarre et oui une vraie polémique
démarre et il ya une députée qui se dit
choqué de la violence dans les mangas
que l'on trouve dans le club dorothée
elle fait monter la sauce et sept
députés à l'époque
à votre avis de qui s'agit-il je
voudrais de leur répondre et moi je
laisse venir alors je connais oui bah
oui bah oui à votre avis qui essaierait
des articles regardez maintenant très
très très connu et c'est elle qui à
l'origine qui est à l'origine de la
polémique qui démarre sur le club
dorothée et donc de l'arrêt du club
dorothée regarde animatrice arrive sur
tf1 avec le club dorothée recette de ce
succès sans précédent des sketches des
chansons et surtout des dessins animés
c'est le début de l' énorme tsunami
manga avec son lot d'action d'humour
mais aussi souvent de sexe et de
violence sont ronds en surfant sur le
phénomène manga ségolène royal sort de
l'ombre et devient l'emblème des valeurs
familiales en dénonçant la violence dans
les émissions pour enfants c'est très
bien que plus un dessin animé viol en
plantant regarde pas ce qui les fascine
et qu'il a peur qu'ils enfants aiment
bien voir peur donc je crois qu'on n'a
pas le droit d'utiliser ce ressort là
pour faire de l'audimat je pense que
c'est injuste et que ça porte atteinte
aux droits de l'enfant alors est très
mignonne
ségolène royal qui avait qu'a lancé la
police à cause d'elle qu'on arrêtait
vrai mais elle a lancé le truc l'allumé
volante à la pâte foutu la lune ségolène
mais il ya aussi une vraie raison de
d'argent c'est que à l'époque la bea qui
lance le bouquet ab ça à cause des
concours avec tf1 terry c'est vrai
surtout aussi sa lancée cette histoire
qui se gare alors vous avez répondu à ce
cvrtak dans un sketch diffusé dans le
club dorothée souvient gens sont de plus
en plus radin c'est qu'est ce que c'est
vous pouvez également visualiser celle
ci c'est un bouquin c'est ça
ségolène royale d'abats c'est bien nul
ça non tout baigne répondu et après de
longues polémiques vous êtes et vous
étiez expliqué chez thierry ardisson
finalement le csa sont est mêlée et on
peut dire que c'est polémique causée par
ségolène royal ont causé l'arrêt de
l'émission
le csa ne vous a pas pris 3 millions
d'euros ils ont arrêté ligne simplement
voilà absolument pas vrai regardez et
vous avez deux temps il a capté goolen
royal ou ségolène royal c'est dante qui
s'appelle le ras-le-bol des bébés
zappeur un jour il y avait une émission
de dorothée du club dorothée et y avait
à rien et corbier qui vidait une
poubelle comme ça il y avait un livre de
ségolène royal devant tu crois que c'est
bien de se servir la télévision pour
répondre aux gens qui nous ont attaqués
c'est à michel c'est pas méchant qu'on a
montré solide à l'antenne ce débat sur
la violence aura des répercussions à
long terme
en 96 le csa et son président de
l'époque hervé bourges instaure une
nouvelle signalétique pour la toute
première fois un logo apparaît sur les
programmes jeunesse jugé choquant alors
voilà et donc ma l'émission s'arrête et
on a on a des images de la dernière est
ce que quand vous voyez ces images à qui
est ce que vous avez une certaine
tristesse ou pas oui oui surtout nos
jours la dernière on était tous très
tristes parce que c'est faux s'est fait
arrêter vraiment assez brutalement quoi
il faut comment ça s'est passé
ils nous ont prévenus de trois mois
avant ah ouais c'était dur quand même
et la dernière du club dorothée qui
était donc le fin diffusé le 31 août
97 on l'a tourné le jeudi moment sur le
plateau il y avait une espèce de sur une
vraie tristesse quoi